si vous vous souvenez mais ya à peu près
un an j'ai été à peu près assez de place
ici sur le plateau de balances ton post
et j'avais 10 ans et j'avais dit un
chiffre j'avais dit que
% des agressions dans les transports en
commun en ile-de-france était le fait
des étrangers et excusez-moi cyrine vous
remercie de m'avoir invité mais à ce
moment là vous m'aviez dit que vous
n'aviez si je l'avais pas les chiffres
vous ne croyez pas eh bien les chiffres
je les ai là c'est le ministère de la
terre vous m'aviez dit de revenir la
prochaine fois d'affilée les chiffres
c'est long mais c'est simplement des
chiffres laissant la part belle moi oui
c'est ça le problème c'est ce à quoi des
chiffres c'est l'épreuve les chiffres je
les ai lacets ministère de l'intérieur
c'est déjà noël 2010 9 63% des
agressions sexuelles dans les transports
en commun sur le fait d'étrangers et je
ne parle même pas des chansons d'origine
oui ça qu'on me reprocher je suis désolé
je mets en fait moi mon témoignage si
j'ai décidé d'en parler c'est que j'en
ai assez de ce tabou que les filles qui
auraient pas quoi en faire renchérit je
suis écouté je suis mais je vous raconte
quelque chose qui m'est arrivé que je ne
souhaite à personne mais aussi toutes
les fois où j'ai été harcelée voir et où
on m'a insulté on m'a manqué de respect
c'était systématiquement tout mon cas
des non blancs et ça c'est en messager
entre madame
vous n'avez pas le droit de dire ça en
france non mais là c'est jarque est à
dire à celle du racing va là
bas je vous remets pas en doute qui peut
t'arriver épouvantail mais vous ne
pouvez pas je moi quand je vous entends
parler je pense à tout ce qui se passe
depuis des dizaines d'années on peut pas
montrer les gens une communauté c'est à
cause de ces oeufs c'est horrible de
faire ça mais
c'est président noir blanc ou jaune mon
propre que vous ayez été adressées ça
c'est un problème c'est le rsa n'est ce
pas évident non militante en exemple
mais faisons prendre garçons c'est moi
je vous dit votre discours je ne peux
pas longtemps et je ne veux plus
l'entendre aujourd'hui je vous l'aï
sincèrement
eisenstein avec des virages où des
gâteaux pour je me dire que ça c'est des
choses que vous pouvez dire ici en
plateau mais en fait les français qui
regardent la télévision de ce soir et
qui vivent dans le réel qui sont le
quotidien qui vivent dans des quartiers
pas dans le 6ème pas dans des quartiers
riches et c'est parce que c'est la
réalité je suis désolé mais je suis sûr
que toutes les filles aunès qui côtoient
le réel et qui agace cette émission
aujourd'hui savent très bien le type de
profil donne peut-être l'auteur dollars
et hessa y en a assez de pression en
mettant le doigt la bordée de dire oui à
la bien pensante je suis désolé je suis
pas bien français avance aujourd'hui moi
je me levais 1 le tabou
après tabou
la preuve vous ne pouvez pas que je le
dise mais c'est une vérité géants et des
chiffres à l'appui et aujourd'hui à
lindsey a sorti un rapport avec le
service statistique ministériel de la
sécurité intérieure du ministère de
l'intérieur je vous mettrais la sauce
machine télégramme si vous ne me croyez
pas les étrangers représentent 7,6 pour
cent de la population française ils
représentent pourtant 30% des vols
violents 28 % des cambriolages 14% des
violences sexuelles ou encore 18 % des
homicides alors voilà ça c'est des
chiffres c'est factuel mais et moi mais
les expériences et il est arrivé il se
débat ils ont tout fait ça si fait seul
déjà sortir des chiffres après cette
agression c'est ça qu'il soit utile mais
ça commence à bien fait agresser fait ça